بالانتقال إلى ما يحدث
والصراع الأوسع في الشرق
الأوسط، فقد شهدنا الآن ثلاث ضربات أمريكية مختلفة
ضد أهداف أه الحوثيين في
الأسبوع الماضي فقط أو نحو ذلك ردًا على
أسابيع من هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار منهم
والصواريخ التي أطلقت على أصولنا  في
السفن التجارية في البحر الأحمر، لقد
رأينا حتى أن أحد أفراد الخدمة أصيب بجراح
خطيرة. هل
تعتقد أن هذه الإستراتيجية هي الآن
الصحيحة التي قالتها الولايات المتحدة إذا
تجاوزت هذا الخط فسنقوم بذلك
الرد كان هناك تجاوز للخط والسؤال الآن
هو هل ينبغي أن يكون هناك المزيد من
الضربات من هذا القبيل من الولايات المتحدة، ما الذي
ستحققه؟
العزيمة والضعف أه ثانيا كنت
أعتقد أن الضربات بينما كانت جيدة طال
انتظارها لا أعتقد أنه يمكنك السماح
لمجموعة إرهابية مثل الحوثيين
بضرب السفن التجارية التي تهدد
السفن الحربية التابعة للبحرية الأمريكية مع
الإفلات من العقاب لذلك أعتقد أنه كان الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب أن
نفعله  الهدف في النهاية هو
الردع، لم يتم ردعهم بعد.
أعتقد أنهم عندما أعلن البنتاغون عن
الضربات الأسبوع الماضي قالوا إن الهدف هو
إضعاف وتعطيل قدرة الحوثيين
على تنفيذ مثل هذه الضربات. أعتقد أنهم
فعلوا بعضًا من ذلك ولكن من الواضح أنهم فعلوا شيئًا
جيدًا.  لا يزال هناك جزء كبير من قدراتهم وأعتقد أننا
يجب أن نستمر في القيام بذلك
حتى نخفض
قدرتهم تمامًا على القيام بذلك أو تحقيق الردع في نهاية المطاف. أود أن
أزعم
أنه يجب علينا ملاحقة مواقع القيادة والسيطرة الخاصة بهم
أيضًا،
وهذا سوف  أضف إليه أيضًا ولكني أعتقد أن
هذا سيستغرق بعض الوقت
لسوء الحظ حتى نجعلهم يوقفون
الشحن التجاري، وانظر إلى
الحقيقة، سيجادل الناس جيدًا،
لا ينبغي لنا أن نفعل ذلك، لا يمكننا القيام بذلك،
وأنا  الرأي هو ما هو الخيار الذي
لا يمكنك السماح بتعطيل 12% من التجارة التجارية و30%
من حركة الحاويات
من خلال هذا الأمر الحيوي أه أه مباشرة
والكارما الاقتصادية التي ستحدثها في جميع أنحاء
العالم هي كما تعلم أنه يمكن قياسها
بالدولار  والوقت نعم بالتأكيد
أريد أن أريكم هذا الفيديو الجديد أه للحوث وهم
يرقصون على سطح
قيادة المجرة في البحر الأحمر
نفس السفينة houie Rebel التي استولى عليها نهاية
العام الماضي عندما تتحدث عن
الردع مرة أخرى السؤال
هو كيف تردع ذلك، أعني أن
سبب قيامهم بذلك كما
يقولون هو
الدعم الأمريكي لإسرائيل في حربها ضد
حماس وهذا الدعم لن
يختفي، فهل تصدق أن ما يفعله هؤلاء
المتمردون الحوثيون  على وشك أن يتم إعلانها
منظمة إرهابية من قبل
إدارة بايدن يمكن ردعها وردعها
جيدًا لا نعرف ولكن
علينا أن نحاول بشكل صحيح أه بالتأكيد
لديهم شهية للصراع مع
الولايات المتحدة وهذا جزء من
فلسفتهم إذا صح التعبير  إنهم يشتركون في
نفس الرأي أه الشيعة للولايات المتحدة
وإسرائيل بأن إيران هل
تعلم الموت لإسرائيل الموت لإيران أنا
آسف الموت للولايات المتحدة ولكن
انظر في نهاية اليوم لقد قلت هذا مرارا
وتكرارا إيران  هو توفير
دعم ملهم أه تمويل كل
هذه الأنشطة سواء كان
الحوثيين في جنوب اليمن أو في اليمن
أو حزب الله حماس والميليشيات الشيعية
في العراق أه سمها ما شئت حتى تعلم أنه
علينا أن نجمع
الديمقراطيات الغربية والدول العربية معًا تمامًا
بصراحة، والتوصل إلى خطة
للتعامل في نهاية المطاف مع إيران لوقف
تدفقات الأسلحة والمواد
والتمويل إلى هذه البلدان، وإلا فإن
هذا سيستمر في
دائرة العنف والإرهاب
لمدة أربعة عقود أخرى،
وهذا ما  نحن نواجه بسرعة
إدارة بايدن على وشك
إعادة تصنيف الحوثيين ككيان
إرهابي محدد بشكل خاص وليس
منظمة إرهابية أجنبية على وجه التحديد ولكن هذا
شيء ألغته
إدارة ترامب
في النهاية  أعتقد أنه كان يوم 11 كانون الثاني (يناير)
ثم جاءت وزارة إعلان العطاءات
وألغت قرارها الآن، لماذا
يهم ما الفرق الذي ستحدثه بشكل
جيد؟ أعتقد أنه سيحدث فرقًا
لأنه سيطبق قدرًا معينًا من
العقوبات على  الحوثيون، أنتم تعلمون أن
قدرة الولايات المتحدة على
التجارة معهم للتعامل معهم
ستضع قيودًا أخرى أيضًا، وأعتقد
أنه كان من الخطأ سحب
العقوبات في عام 2021، وأنا أفهم سبب
اعتقادهم أن ذلك قد ينجح ولكن
الآخر  جزء من هذا هو أنه في حين أنهم
يصنفون مجموعة واحدة من العقوبات
بشكل خاص على أنها إرهابية عالمية
أه فهم ليسوا هم
الإدارة التي لا تطبق
المنظمة الإرهابية الأجنبية نعم
العقوبات التي هي أكثر صرامة بكثير
لديهم عقوبات جنائية والقلق
هو أنها قد تمنع بطريقة أو بأخرى  أو
تخويف المجموعات الإنسانية من وصول المساعدات الإنسانية
إلى الشعب اليمني. يبدو
لي أنه يمكننا إيجاد طريقة لاقتطاع
ذلك بينما لا نزال نطبق
الثقل الكامل للعقوبات الأمريكية على
الحوثيين، وبالمناسبة، لا أفعل ذلك.  تعتقدوننا
العقوبات كافية يجب أن يكون لدينا
عقوبات عالمية بالتأكيد
الديمقراطيات الغربية وغيرها تطبق عقوبات
على اليهود لوقف هذا
السلوك السيء منهم وأه ولسيل
هجماتهم على سفن البحر الأحمر